wer ist schuld daran dass wir jetzt
wieder mitten im corona schlamassel
stecken dass die infektionszahlen durch
die decke gehen das auf den
intensivstationen so viele menschen
sterben und ärzte pfleger nicht mehr
wissen wie sie schaffen können und wie
kann es sein dass trotz viel zu
niedriger impfquoten die impfzentren es
zu machen müssen und man jetzt
verzweifelt versucht sie wieder in gang
zu bringen dass die alten in den heim
wieder nicht geschützt sind weil wir
diesmal mit dem booster nicht
vorankommen ich glaube dass das alles
keine quasi uhr gewaltige
naturkatastrophe ist in diesem inside
politics geht es um uns um gravierende
versäumnisse im bund und ländern und um
eine schwerwiegende frage was kann uns
am ende noch retten
[Applaus]
was war das doch für ein toller sommer
den sie dance unten laune oben es gab ja
auch nichts worüber wir uns hätten
sorgen machen müssen oder wenn wir dann
im herbst sehen die impfquote ist immer
noch viel zu niedrig finde ich muss man
dann weiter nachdenken aber nicht jetzt
heute wie damals ist der satz ein hammer
wie bitte laschet weiß es gibt ein
problem die niedrige impfquote und er
tut nichts aber klar es ist der
bundestagswahlkampf und laschet und
söder scholz baerbock und lindner
interessieren sich vielmehr zu ihrer
umfragewerte als die inzidenz werte oder
ein papier des robert-koch-instituts
dass zwei wochen vor laschet
sommerinterview veröffentlicht wird und
dass laschet und all die anderen hätten
kennen können auch was kennen müssen das
lka warnt darin vor der ausbreitung der
sogenannten delta variante und dass die
impfquote viel zu niedrig sei das rkw
schreibt mit einer zunehmenden dominanz
der delta variante ist in den kommenden
wochen zu rechnen diese wird sich auf
die intensivbetten belegung vor allem
dann auswirken wenn die impfquoten bei
den zwölf- bis 59-jährigen bei 75
prozent oder gar 65 prozent stagnieren
und gleichzeitig eine komplette öffnung
stattfindet der sommer solle dringend
genutzt werden um die impfquote auf bis
zu 85 prozent hoch zu kriegen fordert
das rk und es gab noch andere die
gewarnt haben in diesem sommer aber
nicht gehört wurden am 17 07 eine woche
vor dem laschet interview meldet der
spiegel
wissenschaftler der tu berlin sagen eine
vierte corona welle voraus die auch die
kliniken treffen wird helfen würde
aufgepasst eine hohe impfquoten und an
23 72 tage vor dem laschet interview
warnt christian drosten zitat wenn die
impfquote nicht signifikant erhöht wird
ist eine schwere winter welle zu
erwarten warum erzähle ich euch das
jetzt so ausführlich und warum geht es
die ganze zeit dabei um armin laschet
ist das nicht fies der ist doch nur noch
ex kanzlerkandidat ex ministerpräsident
von nordrhein-westfalen und bald ex
parteivorsitzender aus diesem grund wenn
armin laschet eines kann dann all die
fehler die im bund und in den ländern
gemacht wurden auf einen katastrophalen
satz zusammenschnüren zu lassen wenn wir
dann im herbst sehen die impfquote ist
immer noch viel zu niedrig finde ich
muss man dann weiter nachdenken aber
nicht jetzt dieses nicht jetzt war
wirklich fatal denn es war nicht nur
armin laschet das sagt es war quasi das
sommer motto der bundesregierung und der
länder die sich gleichzeitig noch selbst
auf die schulter klopft dass wir in
dieser schwersten krise in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland bis sie ihr hinauf gut
durchgekommen sind gemeint klingt
grotesk der vierten der schwersten
corona welle aber wirklich dreist ist
was markus söder der bayerische
ministerpräsident behauptet dass nämlich
niemand das hätte ahnen können ja dass
noch nicht einmal die experten davor
gewarnt hätten schauen sie es ist ja
sehr beeindruckend dass nahezu alle
biologen epidemiologen und
wissenschaftler auch die wirkung dieser
neuen welle in ihrer wucht und
geschwindigkeit nicht richtig
eingeschätzt dort noch mal das lka warnt
im sommer christian drosten waren die
wissenschaftler der tu berlin warnen und
und bolt kann es sein lieber markus
söder dass sie die warnungen einfach
nicht hören wollten es war ja
schließlich
bundestagswahlkampf nicht wahr das
tragisch ist ja dass das nicht der erste
sommer ist den bund und länder verpennen
vor einem halben jahr haben wir hier bei
inside politics genau davor gewarnt aber
sie lernen einfach nicht aus den fehlern
und diesmal sind die folgen noch
schlimmer
[Musik]
fast forward aus dem sommer in diesen
düsteren herz die impfquote liegt bei
bescheidenen
68 68 prozent das ist meilenweit
entfernt von den 85 prozent die das lka
im sommer so dringend gefordert hat das
frustrierende daran ist dass das noch
mal kein naturgesetz ist vielleicht
erinnert ihr euch daran dass wir vor
einem jahr nach asien geschaut haben wie
die krone hinkriegen damals sprach mit
lange tendler einen freund der in soul
der hauptstadt südkoreas lebt lasst uns
dann noch mal anrufen hören wie es in
asien im moment aussieht hallo daniel
wie geht es dir
ok ich sag mal das letzte mal haben wir
gesprochen wie die südkorea corona
hinkriegt jetzt ist ein jahr vergangen
wie ist denn die impfquote bei euch
jedenfalls
was glaubst du wenn du das vergleicht
was wenn du es ihm kurz
kurzzusammenfassung ist etwas was hat
südkorea besser gemacht hast deutschland
[Musik]
alles klar ich danke dir
schau daniel
so eine hohe impfquote und kein lockdown
wieso kriegen sie das hin
und jetzt kann man sagen das ist halt
asien aber schaut mal spanien hat fast
80 prozent in quote in italien immerhin
gut 73 prozent im quote warum kriegen
die sachen hin und wir nicht
[Musik]
es macht einen mega unterschied aus ob
man geimpft ist oder nicht ich habe mir
die aktuellsten zahlen des rk ii einmal
angeschaut bei den 18 bis 59 jährigen
kommen ungeimpfte siebenmal häufiger ins
krankenhaus als geimpft auf den
intensivstationen ist die situation noch
krasser wir betreuen patienten in allen
altersklassen zwischen ganz jungen und
fortgeschritten zum ganz ganz ganz
überwiegenden teil um geimpft ist
natürlich nicht schön das schlimme ist
dass nach angaben des verbands der
intensivmediziner in diesem jahr seit
januar 4000 intensivbetten in
deutschland weggefallen sind wie bitte
auf dem höhepunkt der korona pandemie
haben wir plötzlich weniger
intensivbetten woran liegt das hört mal
hier rein in die pressekonferenz des
bayerischen gesundheitsministers wir
haben bitten omas wir haben stationen
die geschlossen sind wir haben bad muss
geräte mehr denn je werden die pandemie
zentrallager noch über glaube ich 840
beatmungsgeräte und in den kliniken auch
an den scheiterns nicht es liegt am
personal der flaschen heißt es das
personal und was haben sie getan um das
problem zu lösen pflegekräfte
eingestellt vielleicht sanitäts pfleger
der bundeswehr an gelernt das thema der
sanitäts kläger das ist nicht mein thema
uns mal ehrlich zu sagen sondern ich
glaube wir haben alles gemacht um das
thema pflege nach vorne zu bringen ein
habt ihr nicht nicht in bayern nicht
anderswo in deutschland jeder hat auf
den anderen gezeigt hat abgewartet
eigenverantwortlich handeln nicht jetzt
wir hatten das schon oder die folgen
allerdings müssen wir jetzt alle aus bad
[Musik]
was die ganze sache noch schwieriger
macht zuerst hatten wir
bundestagswahlkampf jetzt haben wir eine
regierung die bald keine regierung mehr
ist und eine ampel die noch nicht
regierung ist eine zwischenzeit in der
vor allem eines herrscht tatenlosigkeit
in dieser lage passieren dinge die kann
man sich nicht ausdenken helge braun zum
beispiel kanzleramtschef unter merkel
und aspirant auf den cdu parteivorsitz
sagt zum beispiel die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz hat im
august bereits beschlossen dass wir die
booster impfung für die hochbetagten in
den pflegeeinrichtungen machen und
deshalb ist es ganz wichtig dass das
jetzt wirklich schnell umgesetzt wird
ich gebe ihnen völlig recht das hätte
längst passieren müssen hat er recht
aber was hat er dafür getan dass puste
impfungen wichtig sein werden das hätte
man ja an können ja vielleicht sogar
ausrechnen in israel zum beispiel haben
sie schon im sommer mit den booster
impfungen begonnen und wir haben helge
braun der auf die länder zeigt oder die
ampel für das corona chaos
verantwortlich macht die ampel die noch
gar nicht in der regierung ist und wir
haben hendrik wüst den nachfolger von
armin laschet als
nrw-ministerpräsident der verteidigt den
kölner karneval trotz corona und droht
dann dass er das geänderte
infektionsschutzgesetz dass die ampel
eingebracht hat im bundesrat blockieren
könnte ok wüst hat es dann eingesehen
und eingelenkt und auch die ampel hat
natürlich selbst genug probleme
olaf scholz der künftige kanzler war
zuerst abgetaucht und dann hat ein
wirklich flammendes plädoyer gehalten
für entschiedene corona maßnahmen wir
müssen das gemeinsam hinbekommen und wir
werden das auch gemeinsam hinbekommen
uns in dieser situation
auf einen weg zu begeben wie wir es
hinbekommt und bei der fdp hatte man den
verdacht dass es hier mehr um die
kernklientel der gewerbetreibenden ging
als um pandemie schutz marco buschmann
der parlamentarische geschäftsführer
schaffte es ende oktober dann noch das
ende der pandemie auszurufen die
steigenden infektionszahlen haben wir im
blick aber die epidemische notlage von
nationaler tragweite war ja schon nach
geltender rechtslage nur zulässig wenn
eine systemische überlastung des
gesundheitswesen droht und dafür ist
nicht die zahl der infektionen selber
entscheidend sondern die frage wie viele
menschen schwere symptome haben also
behandelt werden müssen auf den
intensivstationen und die zahl nimmt
gott sei dank im verhältnis zu den
infizierten abfall ja sehr viele
menschen schon geimpft sind und die
grünen erklären zunächst dass die ampel
über eine impfpflicht nachdenke um das
ein paar stunden später schon wieder
zurückzunehmen herzlichen glückwunsch
über eine impfpflicht in einrichtungen
gibt es keine einigung wenn ich da
missverstanden worden wenn tut es mir
leid wobei eigentlich hat frau
göring-eckardt ja recht wir müssen die
beine impfpflicht reden bei den
todeszahlen bei denen infektionszahlen
bei der niedrigen in frage
[Musik]
ich höre sie schon alle die jetzt vor
einer spaltung der gesellschaft warnen
als gäbe es diese spaltung nicht schon
längst da eine minderheit der
impfwilligen das ganze land in
geiselhaft nimmt und all die anderen
dies moralisch fragwürdig senden wenn es
eine impfpflicht gäbe ich finde sie
moralisch fragwürdige wenn die
ungeimpften sich selbst und andere
gefährden impfen ist das einzige was
hilft das zeigen die zahlen eindeutig
dann sollten wir es eben auch tun in
frankreich wo die impfquote ähnlich
niedrig ist wie bei uns in deutschland
hat präsident marc angesagt frei sein
bedeutet auch verantwortung und
solidarität zu zeigen es bedeutet könnte
man hinzufügen
gerade nicht nur die freiheit des
einzelnen
schon seit september gilt deshalb in
frankreich im gesundheitswesen eine
impfpflicht und bei uns was sollen wir
tun was kann jetzt noch helfen
schreibt es mehr wir sind gespannt
darauf und wenn euch gefällt was wir
hier machen dann lass dein leichter und
abonniert unseren kanal